in Ross I don't have children but from
the parents that I do talk to that have
college-age kids a lot of the children
of this sort of generation the
Millennial some of them feel that what's
the use you know similar to this the
flower children of the 60s you know like
why fight against this system that
they've seen maybe fail their parents in
some sense you know why even bother to
get a job and have student loan debt
what would you tell someone let's
suppose there's a very creative youth
maybe a little defiant that that feels
like they want to change the world they
want to tell stories but hey I don't
want to have to do it this way I don't
want to have to go through the system
and and I'm just going to go out there
and I'll be the next Robert Rodriguez
and I'll be fine
I think you can be fine I don't think
you have to go to film school to to be a
filmmaker I didn't go to film school I
would venture to say that most people in
the film business did not go to film
school they followed a variety of paths
in their lives that said I also think
there is value to the college experience
I think you it's a time when you mature
as a person but if you really don't want
to go to college when you're 18
don't go get a job and then see what see
what that life is like and how you'll
have those experiences and and maybe
you'll be better off going to college
down the line or maybe you won't find
college fits with your life life at all
I think there are a lot of choices on
ways to go there but and I almost go the
other way 19 I teach at a university and
it's a private university and it's
expensive and so on and sometimes I find
myself saying to there's so much
competition to get into a specific
school I have to go to this place you
see it not just in film school but my
son has to go to Yale or this kid thinks
I have to go to Berkeley or Stanford or
something like that and sometimes I
think they take on so much debt to go to
particular private schools that it may
not be the right move for them there and
I think I think there are a lot of paths
to success and certainly Steven jobs
found a non-college path to success for
himself there or he went for a short
while to a school and got some things
out of it there I mean he's in the book
about him and he's talked about this in
the interview
he his favorite class in college was
calligraphy and it really influenced him
in choosing fonts when they developed
the Macintosh computer and so you get
all kinds of things out of college that
you don't necessarily perceive at the
time as vocational training and I'm a
big advocate for people want to be
storytellers to read whether you do that
through college and taking other courses
or just on your own that's important but
you do not have to go to film school to
get into the film business and you do
not have to go to college to be
successful there are certain jobs where
you do need a college degree if you want
to try and get into the directors guild
training program if you want to try and
get into one of the studio training
programs they're going to require a
college degree but there are many many
paths to success well let's say suppose
someone does want to go to college then
maybe that opportunity isn't waiting for
them but they want to make films what's
just you know what get a DSLR camera
start uploading content to YouTube what
are some of the things that you tell
people that they can do and also some
DIY tips yeah I think those things are
all possible there but you know and I
give this tip to my students as well as
to non students there if you're looking
for the highest percentage way to try
and find work in the film industry learn
how to edit or learn how to do
post-production sound because there's
such a huge need for people to be
skilled at those tasks and everybody
wants to be the director or the writer
but if you can have a real bona fide
skill and it's not just a button-pushing
job they're genuinely creative jobs
people who are sound designers and
people who are editors you're going to
find entry-level work they're not going
to hire you to be the editor on the next
Hobbit film or something like that but
there's so much production of webseries
of reality shows of everything you can
imagine industrial films and selling
that they need skilled competent editors
that you can find a way to pay the bills
and be learning more and more about your
craft every day with a student who is an
excellent editor at Chapman some years
ago who
he did not get her ideal job coming
right out of school she has she so
elegantly described it spent a year
blurring out boobs and balls on for some
sort of reality show but then because
she was getting better and better at it
she became the assistant editor on CSI
on the Las Vegas CSI series and did that
for three or four seasons and now is you
know a bona fide working professional
and so on but it's because she had a
genuine skill that she could Bend out
there in the world
you